bonsoir et bienvenue comme chaque soir
en direct entre 18 et 19 heures du lundi
au jeudi nous allons faire le point sur
l'actualité locale l'actualité dans le
département des yvelines pour débuter
cette heure d'émission je reçois
dominique rey o bonsoir vous êtes
délégué syndical cfdt vous travaillez au
centre médical denis forestier qui est
gérée par la mgen à la mutuelle de
l'éducation nationale un site concerné
par la restructuration programmée de
l'institution aujourd'hui vous avez
manifesté avec plusieurs de vos
collègues sur paris également dans les
différents centres vous avez manifesté
aussi à la verrière là où vous
travaillez
expliquez-nous les raisons de vos de vos
inquiétudes de votre colère dans les
grandes lignes
vous avez peur d'une perte de pouvoir
d'achat de suppressions de postes
peut-être alors en fait 3 à 3 niveaux
nous avons des inquiétudes au niveau de
la dénonciation de la convention
collective qui régit les établissements
de la mgen
en l'occurrence enfin bon entre autres
puisque la mgen alain jeunes il ya 4000
salariés et la convention collective qui
régit les salariés de la mgen regroupe
220 mille salariés sur la france donc
dénonciation de cette convention
collective avec donc une perte
pouvoir d'achat nos pertes est de savoir
d'achat voilà exactement en fait la
dénonciation des conventions collectives
est faite à un seul but c'est de réduire
les déficits des établissements donc les
établissements de soins donc on voit
bien que par là effectivement ça sera
une perte de pouvoir d'achat pour les
salariés donc des inquiétudes à ce
niveau-là des inquiétudes en ce qui
concerne une dénonciation des usages
il faut savoir que donc la mgen toujours
dans un but purement économique donc a
décidé de dénoncer un certain nombre d'
usage et l'eire qui vont externalisés
alors certains services la saison passée
loin le troisième point c'est beaucoup
moins que tu vois là exactement c'est
c'est pour ça que la grogne monte que
nous sommes nous sommes très mobilisés
en ce moment dans un instant là nous
expliquer un petit peu plus à faire et
on détaille justement les raisons de vos
inquiétudes même si on l'a bien compris
elle est palpable elle est réelle en
raison de cette restructuration au
niveau national et puis également en
plateau ce soir maximum pour ce soir et
c'est forcément c'est le jour de la
chronique environnement eh oui si
aujourd'hui on parler d'un sujet très
sérieux comme d'habitude me direz vous
cette fois ci on va pouvoir rigoler et
du tout il s'agit de la colère des
agriculteurs qui était en manifestation
samedi à versailles ils ont rencontré le
préfet pour parler de leurs conditions
de travail apparemment ils sont inquiets
de la disparition des terres agricoles
dans les yvelines au profit de
l'urbanisation et donc nous parlerons de
tout ça avec deux représentants
syndicaux tout à l'heure les
agriculteurs eux aussi en colère
beaucoup d'inquiétude qui vont
s'exprimer ce soir sur ce plateau à tout
à l'heure maxime et puis également
invité tout autre registre ce sera en
culture mellick tir c'est un artiste
yvelinois il prépare un nouvel album mon
ange le tournage du clip avait lieu cet
après midi à saint quentin en yvelines
vous avez peut-être assister c'était sur
la place du théâtre à saint quentin nous
recevons tout à l'heure dans l'émission
voici à présent les titres en images les
principaux sujets d'actualité que nous
allons développer les salariés de la
mgen inquiets pour leur emploi donc une
manifestation nationale s'est déroulé
ce mardi relayer également la verrière
plus de détails dans un instant sur ce
plateau en vie une entreprise
d'insertion qui s'occupe de recycler du
matériel d'électroménager dorénavant
plantes et attrape les salariés signent
des contrats entre quatre et cinq mois
le directeur du site yvelinois sera
également sur ce plateau
les abeilles vont conquérir saint
quentin en yvelines après les sept
ruches
inauguré il ya quelques mois à l'hôtel
d'agglomération attrape la ville de la
verrière elle aussi a dorénavant son
rucher et puis reportage aussi au cours
de cette édition sur sentez vous sport
le sport c'est la santé une un dicton
qui a pris tout son sens c'était ce week
end à la base de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines démonstrations
initiations au programme on va découvrir
ensemble la phrase du jour la phrase de
ce 25 septembre elle est signée arnaud
montebourg il a appelé le constructeur
automobile renault à réinvestir en
france le ministre a poursuivi en
expliquant que la société est très
présente d'ailleurs dans les yvelines
était profitable désendetter et
aujourd'hui internationalisé une
déclaration qui ne manquera pas de faire
réagir alors que le salon de
l'automobile doit s'ouvrir dans moins de
quatre jours concernant d'ailleurs le
salon de l'automobile
je vous précise est ce que le 1er
octobre édition spéciale sur tv fil 78
18 heures nous serons au salon de
l'automobile à la rencontre des
constructeurs des équipementiers qui
sont basés dans les yvelines et qui
feront l'actualité de ces prochains
jours
la mgen ont pleine restructuration je
vous le disais tout à l'heure des
salariés inquiets on en parle tout de
suite c'est le fait du jour
dominique rey au délégué syndical donc
cfdt secrétaire du comité d'entreprise
également de la mgen au niveau national
vous êtes sur le site de la verrière
vous avez manifesté aujourd'hui contre
la restructuration de cette entreprise à
paris et sur le site de la verrière les
images de la mobilisation puisque on
vous a suivi et les explications juste
sur ce plateau après des salariés de la
mgen inquiets pour leur emploi ont
manifesté ce matin à paris dans les
rangs de l'intersyndicale des employés
de l'antenne de la verrière principale
cause de leur mécontentement
la révision annoncée de la convention
collective de la fédération des
établissements hospitaliers et des aides
à la personne
l'aménagement d'usagé propre à la mgen
et l'externalisation de certains
services l'âme je ne s'est pas donné les
moyens de faire une étude de l'intérieur
pour prouver en quoi l'externalisation
et est forcément meilleure mais en quoi
on aurait pu faire différemment à
l'intérieur en termes de ressources
deuxièmement l'ensemble du personnel à
bénéficier régulièrement des formations
et 6 ans d'aujourd'hui hier
dysfonctionnement c'est la
responsabilité de la mgen de nos bases
et tous les moyens pour former et
adapter le personnel ou aux évolutions
qui sont demandés du côté de la
direction locale de la mgen jean ignace
de bayou affirme qu'une réorganisation
est nécessaire pour revenir à un
équilibre financier l'établissement vers
hyérois perd plus d'argent qu'il n'en
gagne
parmi les usages remis en cause on
retrouve notamment les rythmes de
travail et l'institut marcel rivière par
exemple
nous avons
l'habitude de travailler avec des avec
une absence de cycle horaires salariés
n'ont pas de cycle régulier ça a un coût
en équivalent temps plein sur une année
et donc c'est un usage qui est dénoncée
qu'on doit on doit faire des cycles la
mgen compte 33 établissements répartis
dans toute la france ce qui représente
un total de 4000 salariés pour les 200
employés de la verrière une seule
certitude pour l'instant une
externalisation partir du 1er décembre
de la restauration et de l'entretien
le directeur assure que les employés de
ces services seront repris dans les
entreprises sous traitantes
un message entendu mais pas satisfaisant
pour l'intersyndicale qui craint des
suppressions de postes sur ces images
vous êtes de la cfdt vous êtes mobilisés
aujourd'hui vous avez réussi à mobiliser
vos collègues vous étiez nombreux
aujourd'hui puisque il y avait aussi
d'autres établissements franciliens qui
s'étaient regroupés avec nous donc nous
étions dans une centaine de salariés
devant le siège de la mgen pour
manifester notre mécontentement
une vingtaine de salariés avec des
représentants syndicaux ont été reçus
par la direction la direction de la mgen
parle pas de grand scoop par rapport à
ce que l'on peut savoir est ce que l'on
peut nous dire depuis plusieurs mois
d'avancé
non malheureusement malheureusement pas
beaucoup d'avancé parce que la mgen
oppose systématiquement des réalités
économiques auxquelles nous on répond
qu'on peut aussi répondre en interne
leur seule réponse et on va externaliser
donc les inquiétudes des salariés sont à
différents niveaux en fait un puisque
par rapport à l'externalisation
on leur dit vous allez être repris par
une par une entreprise sauf qu'on sait
très bien que si cette entreprise ne
fait pas ne convient pas la mgen et le
contrat pu le dénoncer et à ce moment là
ce serait une autre entreprise qui
reprendrait dans quelles conditions les
salariés ne serait plus alors salariée
monsieur n
et donc on sent bien que effectivement
c'est ce sont des leçons des salariés la
mgen par exemple sur la restauration de
long 2 ans en entreprise tout à fait
tout à fait à l'heure actuelle tous les
salariés qui travaillent dans les deux
établissements de la verrière sont des
salariés et le chevesne ça pourrait
changer donc éventuellement avec cette
restructuration n'est quand on vous
explique comme l'a par exemple le
directeur qu'on entendait dans le
reportage qu'il faut faire forcément des
économies que la mgen ne gagne pas
d'argent il faut bien trouver des
solutions oui alors à ça on répond qu'on
nie tout à fait d'accord et puis que les
syndicats sont des personnes
responsables et on répond par on répond
à ce questionnement par réorganisation
en interne on sait très bien que de
toute façon une société une société
prestataire qui va intervenir dans nos
établissements
elle va faire des économies par quel
biais par la réduction du personnel
donc on pouvait aussi réfléchir en
interne et voir enfin réfléchir avec la
direction des établissements et
redimensionner l'activité voir comment
on pouvait grâce à l'injection la
gestion prévisionnelle des emplois et
des compétences lors de départs à la
retraite ne pas remplacer tel ou tel
poste et donc arriver à faire des
économies en interne en gardant nos
salariés au sein de la mgen ce que vous
reprochez mgm ses bras ne pas vous avoir
consulté ne pas avoir consulté
l'intersyndicale avant oui arriver à
faire là bon effectivement il y a eu
quelques consultations mais qui sont
très à la marge qui aurait pu être
beaucoup plus en profondeur
aucune consultation quant à des
alternatives
on reproche aussi à la mgen de ne pas
avoir cherché par elles mêmes des
solutions alternatives à l'intérieur de
faim avec ses salariés et en gardant ses
salariés fabien juste sur cette
convention collective dont on parlait en
début d'émission
aujourd'hui donc elle serait dénoncé la
fédération des établissements
hospitaliers et d'aidé à la personne
donc a pris la décision de dénoncer
cette convention collective qui
s'applique aux personnels de la mgen
ça veut dire une baisse sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur le salaire des dessins
dénonciation de la mise en application
de la dénonciation ce serait en décembre
alors en fait non ça ce serait enfin si
les conséquences directes pour le
salarié les conséquences directes pour
les salariés c'est une perte de cercles
de certains acquis la convention fait à
part fait les employeurs de la
convention fait ap ont dénoncé 15 points
de la convention collective
c'est 15 points coller de la convention
collective concerne un certain nombre
d'avantagés qui était réservée aux
salariés et que par là mais l'ancienneté
par exemple la prime d'ancienneté qui
peut reculer alors dans ça c'est la
prime oui la prime d'ancienneté 1% par
an qui ensuite seraient calculées
suivant une autre modalité et qui ferait
au bout du compte que à salariés qui
arriverait en bout de à la fin de à la
fin de sa carrière perdrait 1% 5 % de
pouvoir d'achat par rapport à ce qu'ils
auraient eu autrement 1 re calcul de la
prime de départ à la retraite aussi
qu'ils seraient moins avantageuses une
perte une perte de certains avantages
comme
la récupération de jour férié un autre
une autre perte davantage en ce qui
concerne la rémunération des heures
supplémentaires de dimanche et jours
fériés qui était qui était à 100 à 100 %
fin 200% en fait et qui passerait donc à
une rémunération à 125 voire 150 % en
fonction des heures des heures à à
régler enfin payer donc voilà il ya
différents points comme ça dans le sens
où enfin ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
la ferme s'ils ont de si l'afer peut
dénoncer un certain nombre d'articles la
convention collective
c'est justement pour faire des économies
des économies sur les salaires donc
forcément à un moment donné les salariés
vont le retrouver au niveau de
rémunération
si c'est pas instantané ce sera sur tout
au long de la carrière en fait ça
explique votre mobilisation notamment
aujourd'hui mais ça a commencé il ya
déjà quelques mois on va parler de la
suite du mouvement justement mais ce que
la négociation aujourd'hui est encore
possible
cet après midi vous nous avez dit sympa
a servi à grand chose est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres rendez-vous de planifier avec
la direction pour les syndicats alors
non non non à l'heure actuelle il n'y a
aucun rendez-vous de planifier en ce qui
concerne la convention collective c'est
un mouvement beaucoup plus large qui va
qui va avoir lieu en l'occurrence on a
une première date qui est annoncé au 15
novembre
et là qui concernera les 220 mille
salariés qui sont régis par cette
convention collective
après en ce qui concerne les événements
qui sont propres à la mgen n'ont pour le
moment il n'y a aucun rendez vous c'est
une ce si ce n'est les rendez-vous les
gauff avons donc les cce laisser eux
mais qui sont d information consultation
et au delà desquels la mgen peut faire
ce qu'elle veut à partir du moment où
elle a eu
même si même si les élus se prononcent
contre un projet la mgen peut continuer
ensuite sur ce projet sans être sans
être ennuyés de quelques façons que ce
soir que sur cette question justement
des négociations des discussions à venir
nous avons également rencontré cet après
midi jean ignace de bayou c'est le
responsable sur le site de la verrière
de la mgen écoutez le ce qui est
important c'est d'arriver à voir une
certaine souplesse et la négociation qui
est importante que je comprends la
demande
de nos organisations c'est d'avoir cette
souplesse est ce que cette souplesse est
possible est-ce qu'il faut que la règle
soit la même dans tous les
établissements va ce sont des
négociations qui se font mais qui se
font pas en dans les établissements qui
se font au niveau central au siège des
discussions au niveau central au siège
même si elle vous nous l'avez dit n'y a
pas de réunion vraiment de programme et
un de prévu prochainement là pour faire
le point de la dessus est ce que vous
n'avez pas peur d'une vaste étude pour
conclure ce des salariés et se
mobilisent mais n'y a pas de réunion
prévue c'est une guerre d'usure
alors oui c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
les salariés commença à 5
parce qu'on sait le climat social est
aussi tendue donc on va se dire au final
on conserve notre emploi même s'il ya
des baisses de salaires même si on perd
des acquis des avantages au moins on
aura conservé notre emploi n'était pas
le cas partout
enfin c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'on pense
que la mgen joue un petit peu sur ce
terrain là et qu'elle espère qu'au bout
d'un moment effectivement les salariés
vont commencer à se lasser et puis moi
je veux dire à partir d'un moment il ya
une perte de pouvoir d'achat
on a aussi des salariés qui ont le smic
ou quelquefois même en salaires
conventionnels n'ont même pas le smic
ont une ligne de rattrapage de smig faut
le savoir ça on a un certaine on a 25 %
de salariés qui sont dans ce cas de
figure donc des salariés qui ne peuvent
pas se mettre en grève parce qu'ils
n'ont pas la possibilité pécuniaire la
possibilité financière de se mettre en
grève donc et puis en plus on est dans
des établissements de soins donc
obligation grève à leurs obligations
aussi d'intervenir auprès des patients
et ce qui fait aussi qu'on n'était
peut-être pas très très nombreux à aller
au siège ou ensuite après se retrouver à
la verrière mais sur le terrain dans les
établissements il y avait aussi un
soutien de quasiment tous nos tous nos
collègues qui soir au ray
un brassard soit du débrayage aussi de
quelques débrayages de quelques heures
des réunions d'information enfin voilà
c'est ça ça pue englober un certain
nombre certain nombre de manifestations
différentes en fonction des endroits en
fonction des possibilités
merci dominique rénaux d'être venu sur
le plateau je rappelle donc que les
syndicats s'inquiètent
elle est salariée également de la
restructuration annoncée du côté de la
mgen manifestation aujourd'hui à paris
et puis dans les différents centres mgm
notamment à la verrière merci à vous
dominique rey o on va parler maintenant
de recyclage un recyclage solidaire on
passe à la virgule société